so let's jump to this story first before
we get to the Elon Musk stuff we have
this from grit daily I'm not familiar
with grit daily and I think they're
wrong on this story here's what they
said following PR crisis PayPal again
updates TOS hoping you won't notice they
say as far as PR crises go PayPal's
gotten itself into quite a predicament
on October 8 the company updated its
terms of service to include a clause
enabling it to withdraw 2500 from users
bank accounts simply for posting
anything the company deems as
misinformation or offensive
unsurprisingly the backlash was instant
and massive who would have guessed that
the consumers don't want a company to
take to police their speech and threaten
to drain their bank accounts aside from
the fact the Claus is a Fool's Aaron
because there's literally no way for the
company to legitimately determine what
is or isn't misinformation okay full
stop guys they would it it actually said
at their discretion
so he goes in to say it's another case
of big Tech overreach so a lot of people
are pointing it out but let me let me do
this here's PayPal's actual user
agreement it says if you are this is
current right now I just Googled it if
you're a current seller and receive
funds for transactions that violate the
acceptable use policy then in addition
to being subject to the above actions
you will be liable to PayPal for the
amount of PayPal's damages caused by
your violations of the acceptable use
policy you acknowledge and agree that 2
500 US dollars per violation of the AUP
is presently a reasonable minimum
estimate of PayPal's actual damages
including we're not limited to internal
administrative costs incurred blah blah
blah so so there it is they're not
saying right now they are going to
deduct it from your account but it is
there
and right now so this is an archive from
two years ago which basically says the
exact same thing you acknowledge and
agree with twenty five hundred dollars a
permanent you know per violation is the
is reasonable minimum estimate here's
what they determine currently to be
unacceptable they uh the promotion of
hate violence racial other forms of
intolerance that is discriminatory or
the financial exploitation of a crime
so of course that's at their discretion
so let me just stress right now
and you know admittedly this is at risk
to us we still have many members of our
website timcast.com who are using PayPal
if that's you I recommend you uh sign up
using parallel economy send a email send
an email to members at timcast.com we
will do our best to help you get
switched over it's not partake it's not
super easy but uh we used to use PayPal
we removed it from the website but there
are so many people who still do use it
it's still there if you are using PayPal
you need to find an alternative I
recommend parallel economy at Stan
bongino's company they got a lot of work
to do to get set up it's not as easy
with you know PayPal you click your open
account it's done that's why they
dominate but we've got to get away from
this stuff because right now they said
it right there you agree that 2500 bucks
is reasonable damages if you espouse
discriminatory speech what does that
mean does that mean if I say something
like
um on average I would prefer a male
firefighter to save me over a female one
look like I'm not I'm not going to play
games I think there there's a there's it
doesn't matter if you're a male or a
female if you want to be a firefighter
but on average based on muscle mass
bound density and height it's probably
going to be you preferring a male what I
mean by that is there are six foot tall
women who are super strong I'll tell you
this I would rather see a six foot tall
woman than a five foot tall man if I was
trapped in a burning building and needed
help however typically you are going to
see the height skew men are going to be
taller and more muscle mass if I say
that was PayPal gonna boot us from the
web from from our website are they going
to kick off our customers are they going
to charge me now 2500 bucks per customer
what is a stupid game well it's per
violation and they're saying that if you
one of the things they're saying is that
if you incur damage to PayPal's brand so
if I tell people to cancel their PayPal
account I'm technically they could say
hey every every time that that was
uttered every Play that video had if I
have 10 000 views every every one of
those views counts towards an instance
of the violation of of denouncing our
brand like I'm canceling my PayPal
account tonight I've been using it for
20 minutes and I don't stress it does
say PayPal May deduct such damages
directly from any existing balance in
any PayPal account you control so let me
stress right now at paypal.com
they say they may deduct at minimum
twenty five hundred dollars if you
engage in a variety of activities
including discriminatory speech
promotion of hate yeah now who gets to
decide what is discriminatory speech who
gets to decide what is quote hate why
are these rules so General vague and and
to the point where it could be
interpreted in so many different ways
they do that because again this is akin
to a social credit score they know
PayPal is one of the biggest online
banking institutions on the entire
internet and right now they're saying we
could do whatever we want we want to
steal money from you we will which is
absolutely crazy will they find me for
having a PayPal account right now maybe
who knows that's how vague these rules
are and again PayPal has been becoming
more of an activist organization more
and more they work with the splc a
discredited organization that has been
successfully sued before for defaming
defaming people for lying about people
they they actually moved out of North
Carolina because North Carolina does
decided to have a policy where they said
biological sex individuals people have
to use bathrooms based on their
biological sex so they're acting more
and more like an organization that wants
to of course play political games and
push their political ideas rather than
of course just be a bank just be a bank
for for Frick's sakes it's not that hard
I just want to point out it's funny that
this policy has been in place for years
and no one knew it was good but it's
like nobody actually read the terms of
in conditions it was kind of like when
Zuckerberg went on Rogan was like yeah
the FBI asked us to censor and no one
really like it was obvious we all kind
of knew that for the last few years
since he testified but it was like I
think mines tweeted out Bill ottman
tweeted it out I was like yo everyone
focus on this because that's crazy well
everyone focus on this PayPal Clause can
they did they say they can also take
2500 out of your bank account out of
your PayPal account it also says items
that are considered obscene obscene by
who yeah really like like I don't know
we're talking about sexual toys the
other layer here is is not just all
right what are what are they going to
punish here discriminatory speech hate
speech but damage to their brand which
they're saying well we can't really tell
you what the damage to our brand is so
we're gonna put in this little
liquidated damages clause for 2500 so
not only determining what's hate speech
what's discriminatory but also what's
damaging to their brand which none of
it's going to be damaging to their brand
but they put that in there as just
another layer for them to enforce it and
saying well this is why we need to do it
there these rules are damaging to the
Brand It also says Luke you might want
to earmuffs this one it says content
that relates transactions involving
ammunition Firearms or certain firearm
parts or accessories blasphemy
absolutely horrible I mean that that
right there just shows you how much of a
political organization that they are how
they're just playing again
social justice Warrior politics that
they're trying to push for the Forefront
in reality people just want a bank
people just want to use Finance people
just want to be able to trade and barter
and of course make money and sell money
and and sell products why are we having
to deal with all this nonsense why are
they putting these rules into place
that's a question that I think a lot of
PayPal users should be asking themselves
today I used to feel like I needed a
PayPal account because paying online was
really a hassle I'd have to put in my
bank card I have to put in this now that
data saved for me I don't need to go
through it's like do I want to pay with
my card that's saved in steam or do I
want to pay with PayPal it's like 50 50
coin toss I don't need PayPal I don't
need it for anything at the moment I
don't nothing and then they have things
like stripe which are which are doing
the exact same function newer better so
privately owned that's why we use stripe
and we we default parallel economy so if
you want to become a member at
timcast.com using parallel economy
supports the company which is Dan
bongino's company we use Rumble
infrastructure for everything and you
support us directly so I'm very excited
about it me too I got a question I mean
I see a copy of uh genderqueer there
does does that mean that somebody would
violate PayPal's rules if they um you
know sell that book or wrote that book
online well that's only determined by
the people that are running paper no
technically yes but it does say uh
sexually oriented materials or services
well it says it says certain but it's
obscene a lot of people consider that
obscene so if someone you if they use
PayPal to transact for that wait doesn't
can't you use PayPal for Amazon or no
can you I think so yeah I think you can
oh we got a problem here PayPal Amazon
is outright violating your policies
because Amazon sells a whole lot I
haven't used it in a while but I'm gonna
do it right now and see if I can pull up
a PayPal cool man I've left I've had
PayPal for 20 years why are these
companies getting political is our
PayPal's always been bad well Elon
started the thing Elon and uh what's his
name Peter Thiel Peter Thiel guys how
they exploded onto the scene well that's
how they got a lot of their you know by
using PayPal Ian on Amazon
you got to be able to right I think so
yeah I don't know I'm not sure there's
also a lot of gun accessories on Amazon
as well that are available to purchase
um but but I think a lot of this
correlates with the ESG score it could
be people at PayPal being like hey we
want more investment money hey we want
more Federal Reserve BlackRock money hey
how do we do that let's just do exactly
what they want us to do and implement
the ESG social credit score system where
of course we comply we push all the woke
nonsense we push all the politicking
onto the individuals and we make sure
that of course we play along with the
game that the globalists and other
centralized Bankers want us to play I do
not see uh PayPal on Amazon to be honest
I oh okay maybe not yeah maybe not maybe
not because otherwise they'd be
violating their own policies thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there